a little while back we spoke to Alex
from bite sized about her number color
synesthesia basically how she sees
numbers as colors the video created a
lot of interest and a lot of comments
from you guys as viewers one of the
things you did was you all sent in what
color you think numbers are we've taken
that information and done a bit of work
with it to create a few graphs and other
things but I'll have more about that at
the end of the video the other thing was
you had loads of questions for Alex
herself now a little while ago I caught
up with her at an event and I had all of
your questions so I set her down and
asked some of them now one of the things
a lot of you said was you thought she
was making it up so I asked Alex that no
I Hawaii how do we know you're not
making it up I I guess it's hard I mean
as a scientist I encourage skepticism
and I want to be able to show you in my
head and show you data points but I I
can't you're just going to have to take
my word for it have you been to a doctor
has it been diagnosed
I haven't actually that's a good point I
know that I make these associations
between numbers and colors very strongly
and synesthesia is the best word that i
have found to describe that do the
numbers give you the colors what are the
colors give you the numbers the numbers
give me the colors so if I see a color
it doesn't back translate into a number
but if I see a number then I can see the
color it helps me to memorize things
it's really good for memorizing phone
numbers so another thing that came up in
the previous video was that sometimes
the color of a number was created by its
factors so some of you asked could Alex
take a number look at its color and then
kind of reverse engineer the factors
just by using the color so I asked no
unfortunately the factors influence the
color of the number if I already know
them so for something like 14 7 is such
a huge part of 14 to me that that yellow
is really prominent in there but if I
see a giant number I unfortunately
cannot see a color with it and pull it
back how do you see prime numbers so it
depends really on what the prime number
is so something like 13 it's really a 1
and a 3 it has a lot more to do with
their digits only the things really from
zero
ix have their own specific colors if
they're prime numbers one on its own is
just white if it's just a single digit
but when it can be combined with other
things so in ten and a hundred and a
thousand then it takes on that sort of
black flicker almost if you see numbers
written down on a piece of paper like in
black print which is the most common
thing mm-hmm
do they become colourful for you no so
when they're still on that page they
just exist in whatever color they are
whatever color that print is but when I
think about that number when it sort of
moves into my head then it takes on the
color but the ink on the page stays the
same color I unfortunately do not think
about numbers and bases very often and
so I think because my brain really works
on a base-10 system it's just the digits
0 to 9 that have their own colors if I
were to think in base 6 you know I would
still just see the digit 1 5 and not and
not translate it these mathematics a
sort of colorful psychedelic experience
I don't think I would consider it to be
psychedelic it is colorful I mean I am
seeing these colors in my mind but
because that's just the way I've always
experienced the numbers it's not weird
to me it's not distracting to me it just
they are numbers a lot of other people
who responded to this video said that
for them numbers have personalities or
genders do you associate personalities
or genders with any numbers I do so
that's actually how I sort of realized
that I was seeing these colors is that I
had had that sort of gut reaction in
class that numbers have personalities
not colors and so I think the example I
gave before is that 9 is a very dark red
and so it seems like sort of an angry
number to me whereas the two 4 and
eights or sort of cooler numbers they
seemed a little bit more chill and they
seemed a little bit more friendly but I
that's that's really sort of the realm
of things R + 7 is not intrinsically
jealous because it's yellow but sort of
basic personalities of nice or mean
gender no gender no can you give me a
color for these numbers because these
are just numbers paper last for sure 79
79 is yellow and that nine maroon at the
same time so it's not like you've mixed
it's two things it is for much of the
larger digit numbers yeah so things that
are I would say probably below 40 is a
lot more mixing I think because I do
know those factors and I thought about
those numbers a lot more but the higher
ones is really just the digits it's as
if you had to sort of colored sheets of
cling film one that was yellow and one
that was that maroon and sort of laid
them over each other so it's not really
like you're mixing paints I understand
that there are two separate things but
they're existing in the same space 854
million six hundred and eighty five
thousand two hundred and fifty four as
you're saying them I can see the you
know blue black blue but it does not
exist as one whole number in my head and
now I show it to you I'm showing it Gina
oh yeah still so the digits all have
their own thing but I think because I'm
not processing the like quantity that is
that large number just the digits have
their own identities fractions fractions
I just look like a digit over a digit
negative numbers the negative doesn't
have any impact on the colors irrational
numbers so how do you deal with pi with
pi so pi as a symbol it doesn't have
anything it's just a symbol but if I
think of 3.14 then it does take on the
you know red white and blue I can do pi
222 digits
I hope I still can 3.14159265 three five
eight nine seven nine three two three
eight four six two was anything colorful
happening in your head then I mean as I
say the digit I can see the color but
it's not creamy itself all into one big
color all right and complex numbers and
imaginary numbers again they don't have
digits to me and so if I think of I you
know as a number I guess then it does
but I itself is just I the final thing
is a lot of people responded to what you
had to say in the last video and like
sort of understood what you were saying
but completely disagreed about the
colors said Alex is wrong that's not
that color it's just color and they even
gave whole sets of what they think the
colors are mm-hmm
what do you say to that I completely
understand that because I've seen people
give me those sets as well and I have
that same reaction of so that's wrong
it's such an intrinsic link to me that I
don't get that people can I mean I
understand logically that people can
the other colors but no.3 is red I don't
know what you green is 3 people are
saying 3 is red what is 5 again 5 is
black so look at those five chairs there
yes what what do you feel about that
it's funny because if I don't I mean
it's fine this does not impede my life
um but it is wrong I think it's I think
it's more with things under 10 because
you can sort of see the quantity and
understand at the same time if I had to
count every chair in here I wouldn't be
very upset that you know all the white
chairs if there were 20 white chairs and
they were all white that would be fine
but yeah that's now that you brought it
up yeah it's not right so thanks so much
to Alex for talking to us more about
this subject which so many of you find
interesting
now also all of those comments from last
time and all of the colors that you guys
attributed to numbers have been analyzed
by dave wiley our resident graph number
expert who helps us out and he's come up
with this this is a graph showing the
most popular colors for each number this
is going to be on my blog so have a look
at the link under the video description
if you want to pore over this in more
detail but also dave has put this
together based on the HSV color space
this is kind of the average color of
each number so here we go 0 1 2 3 4 5
lot of greens you can see 6 7 8 again
more green but then we go 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 and this is where Dave stopped for
now because the data started getting a
bit thin after that 19 of you said that
numbers to you seem to have genders 13
people said days of the week have colors
and the area of most agreement amongst
all of you as viewers was that the
number 27 is green so there you have it
this video has been brought to you by
Squarespace which is an all-in-one
platform for designing your own websites
blogs portfolios online stores they've
got a whole range of templates you can
use to get your site looking just how
you want but then you can customize it
you can choose your own colors maybe
you're going to choose green after this
video but you can get it just how you
like and one of the best things about it
is you can design your website and it
automatically changes for people who are
viewing it on mobile phones so check it
out here's the website here's what some
of those websites can look like you can
sign on for free and if you decide to
buy anything you can get 10% off by
using the code numberphile 5 Squarespace
comm numberphile 5 for the discount and
thanks to Squarespace for supporting
numberphile and making videos like this
possible